JENNY BROWN: This
week, we're talking
about the new E2 VMs,
Packet Mirroring,
and climate data sets.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Compute Engine is a
powerful tool for any cloud
solution you want to build.
And we want to make
sure great solutions are
available to everyone.
To help with that, we've begun
the beta program for the new E2
Virtual Machines.
These general purpose
VMs are cost optimized
without compromising
flexibility or reliability.
And speaking of
beta programs, we've
also just launched
Packet Mirroring to beta.
Packet Mirroring allows
you to troubleshoot
your existing virtual private
clouds using third party tools,
ensure the security and
compliance of your workloads
by identifying network
anomalies at all levels--
across VPCs, between VMs, and
even down the line to your end
locations.
Google Public Datasets
or a collection of data
sets that are available
at no charge to anyone
wanting to explore
modern data analytics
or researching innovative
solutions to complex problems.
We're excited to be a
part of this collaboration
to host the latest climate
simulation data in the cloud.
Now researchers all
around the globe
can use updated and consistent
environmental data models
without downloading
terabytes of data.
The "Art of SLOs"
is a workshop that
teaches the essential elements
of developing service level
objectives to audiences
from Dev, Ops, product,
and business.
And now we're releasing
the workshop materials
under a Creative
Commons license.
So anyone may host their
own version of this workshop
to teach their coworkers
or customers, best friends,
you name it.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Go ahead and leave us
a comment or tweet us.
We'll see it in the cloud.